our Republican areas the reason for
declining life expectancy our democratic
area is the reason for rising income
inequality and are you your own soul
mate I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected and expressvpn calm slash
man what exactly are you waiting for
okay so we'll get to all impeachment
gate related things a little bit later
on in the program I'll be honest with
you I'm kind of bored with the
impeachment stuff I feel like most
people are kind of bored with the
impeachment stuff because nothing much
is happening the Republicans did release
a long report about a hundred and twenty
page report on the impeachment gate
related stuff basically the report says
exactly what you'd expect it to say that
none of it holds up to scrutiny that
basically the charges are empty that the
Democrats haven't proved their case the
Democrats did apparently present in
committee their own impeachment report
which will say exactly the precise
opposite they have not released that one
publicly yet when it comes out we will
analyze it with all of that said we're
basically in a holding pattern right now
because no new information is coming out
because the impeachment procedures are
moving forward in the Judiciary
Committee but the Trump administration
is not taking place the White House is
not taking part the White House is not
sending any counsel there saying that we
have not been given any guidance on
exactly what we're even supposed to be
doing there and no new facts are being
brought to bear at this point and we all
know where this is going anyway the
Democrats are gonna vote to impeach
Trump in the house and it's gonna go to
the Senate and then the Republicans
aren't gonna do anything in the Senate
so basically the only question right now
is a question of timing it's a question
of when not of if everybody knows what's
going to happen and so we'll get into
sort of those developments a little bit
later we'll also get into developments
surrounding the Inspector General report
the IG is supposed to put out a report
next week with regards to the Trump
Russia collusion investigation and its
origins as to whether that was initiated
in good faith or whether it was
initiated in bad faith apparently
there's some conflict between the IG of
the of the Department of Justice and
William Barr the Attorney General we'll
get to all of that in a little bit but I
want to talk about something that I
think is is more important right now and
that is the belief that is prevalent
across the country that every problem in
a particular area is due to differences
in politics that it's not overall trends
in the United States that are affecting
differences in the United States it is
in fact local politics now listen people
on the right are guilty of this people
on the left are guilty of this the fact
is that when you have a local problem
like say homelessness where homelessness
is endemic in a city and the only
authority czar capable of taking care of
that are the authorities in the city
then obviously you're gonna look to the
local authorities and see exactly how
they're handling the problem is Utah
handling a Salt Lake City handling the
problem differently than Los Angeles
how is seattle handling the problem
compared to Oklahoma City and what are
the effects of that right you're gonna
look at differences in policy when
you're looking at broad national trends
like for example declining life
expectancy or when you are looking at
broad national trends like the opioid
epidemic or like income inequality how
much of that is due to local policy and
how much of that is due to broad
national trends now the reason this
matters is because folks on the Left are
apt to suggest that problems that seem
to be located more heavily in red areas
are the fault of red state governors and
red state partisanship and folks on the
right are apt to suggest that problems
that are more prevalent in blue areas
are obviously the result of blue state
partisanship and blue state governments
but the truth is that the more endemic
problems in American society right now I
don't think are actually especially the
result of local governance they seem to
be much more the result of broad
national and international trends and
the reason this is important again is
because it is very easy to get caught up
in the idea that if for example there's
an opioid epidemic that seems to be
predicated largely in red states that
this is the result of red state
governance if only they'd expand
Medicaid then that would fix the opioid
epidemic problem not a lot of evidence
to suggest that on the other hand you
see from folks on the right that as
income inequality rises in major cities
in in places like New York that this
must be the fault of democratic
governance in those cities if we're not
for democratic governance in those
cities income inequality would be
falling again I don't think that that is
necessarily true either
okay so let's jump into why this subject
matters so today there's an article in
The New York Times talking about the
wealth poverty divide in American cities
and what this article basically shows is
that America's largest cities are the
most income and unequal those are the
areas where income has divided the most
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk for a second about the
fact that you're an adult and that means
that you need life insurance so stop
whatever you're doing and go get life
insurance right now well how can you do
this how can you do this and not spend a
fortune doing it well you should go
check out my friends at policy genius
policy genius we'll find you the right
insurance at the best price and do all
the work to help you get covered you
just need to get in
touch with them policy genius makes
finding the right life insurance a
breeze in minutes you can compare quotes
from the top insurers and find your best
price you could save fifteen hundred
dollars or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also can help you do home
insurance and auto insurance and
disability insurance they can do all of
these wonderful wonderful things for you
so all you need to do is check out
policy genius.com
again that is a way to competitively
shop and ensure that you are in fact
getting the best deal policy genius.com
it takes only a few minutes to find the
right insurance policy apply and cross
another thing off your to-do list so go
get it done right now policy genius when
it comes to life insurance it is nice to
get it right and policy genius or ensure
that you do again that is policy
genius.com go check them out right now
over at policy genius com okay so
there's an article in The New York Times
today all about the wealth poverty
divided and kind of unsurprisingly it
finds that the wealth poverty divide is
the greatest in large American cities so
all the places where you would expect
the left to complain the least are the
places that the highest income
inequality according to the New York
Times in 1980 highly paid workers and
Binghamton New York earned about four
and a half times what low-wage workers
there did the gap between them in a
region full of IBM executives and
manufacturing jobs was about the same as
the gap between the workers near the top
and the bottom in Metro New York since
then the two regions have diverged IBM
shed jobs in Binghamton other
manufacturing disappeared two
high-paying work in the new knowledge
economy concentrated in New York and so
did well-educated workers as a result by
one measure wage inequality today is
much higher in New York than it is in
Binghamton in fact if you look at the
chart that the New York Times has put
together the ratio of 90th percentile
wages to 10th percentile wages in 195
metro areas cities like New York
Washington DC Chicago San Francisco they
far outpaced cities like Binghamton New
York in terms of income inequality San
Jose tremendous income inequality
fairfield connecticut tremendous income
inequality according to the New York
Times what has happened over the last
four decades is only partly a story of
New York's rises of global hub and
Binghamton struggles economic inequality
has been rising everywhere in the United
States but has been rising much more in
the booming places that promised hefty
incomes to engineers lawyers and
innovators and those places today are
also the largest metros in the country
New York LA
francisco san jose houston and
washington this particular chart put
together by the new york times using
data from a recent analysis by jason
abel and richard deets of the new york
fed captured several dynamics that have
remade the US economy since nineteen
eighty thriving and stagnant places are
pulling apart from each other and within
the most prosperous regions inequality
is widening to new extremes that this
inequality now so clearly correlates
with city size the largest metros are
the most unequal also shows how changes
in the economy are both rewarding and
rattling when we have come to think of
as superstar cities in these places
inequality and economic growth now go
hand in hand in other words as we move
from manufacturing based economy to a
service based economy as we move from a
place where physical labor makes up a
large part of the wage base to a place
where capital intense capital intensity
and intellectual labor makes up a large
part of the of the wage base what you
are starting to see is rising wages in
one sector of the economy and stagnating
wages in another sector of the economy
so in big cities where you had a lot of
people living who are not actually part
of the quote-unquote knowledge economy
and then you have a bunch of people who
are being drawn to this knowledge
economy and companies that are moving in
because there are a lot of major
universities there and have the
intellectual capital you're starting to
see the income gap widen and this is not
exactly a result of city policy per se
this is more a result and and high rates
of taxation are not dampening this high
rates of taxation are not actually
solving the problem right seattle has
pretty high city taxes LA has really
high city taxes New York has extremely
high city taxes redistribution isn't
going to do the trick instead what we
are watching in the united states and
again this is a broad national trend so
cities are where it's most obvious just
because cities are the place where a lot
of these new jobs are being created but
what we are watching is the knowledge
economy the wages are taking off and in
the old manufacturing economy the wages
are not taking off in the same way and
this is what has led to so much social
unrest it's what led to this sort of
populist uprising the the the economic
move against capitalism in many cases
this belief that capitalism is gonna
leave too many people behind even though
we are creating jobs at an exorbitant
rate in the United States even though we
are reaching all-time low levels of
unemployment in the United States
there's a feeling that some groups in
America are leaving other groups in
America behind and those groups in
America that are being left behind are
not just being left behind by the
economy they're also being left behind
in terms of social values
it's a broad national trend and so
blaming that on major cities and
suggesting that major cities are the
problem is not right on behalf of the
right wing on the other hand it is also
not correct on behalf of left-wingers
that it's our major cities that are
driving American growth because of
liberal governance that is not correct
major cities are driving American growth
right now because we are shifting from a
manufacturing based economy into a
knowledge-based intellectually based
economy and that is changing the nature
of the economy so when you hear people
on the Left say things like what blue
states are richer than red states that's
not because they're blue states the
reason that they are richer than red
states very often is because these are
major metropolitan areas when you have
major metropolitan areas and people live
closely together they're very tempted to
have government step in but those are
also the areas where you have high
levels of income inequality
it's the areas we're gonna have a San
Jose like city with a bunch of homeless
people living on the street and people
living in pens houses it's where you
have tremendous levels of growth but
also a lot of underclass stagnation
economically speaking right that is not
the fault of the liberal city nor is it
to the credit of liberal cities and on
the other hand you have people like Paul
Krugman
suggesting that declining life
expectancy in red areas is due to red
state culture which of course is not
true either right is just possible that
the reason that a lot of red states are
voting red is because they are trying to
cling to some form of institution that
is going to fill in the gap that is
being left by the economy in other words
as people move to blue cities in order
to get jobs as the economy stagnates in
a lot of red states people are saying we
need to fill the social gap with
something that is going to provide us a
sense of meaning we need we need a
restoration of a certain sense of social
morality the left ripped away over the
course of decades the reason that comes
up is because Paul Krugman has an awful
column today in the New York Times it's
incredibly simplistic and statistically
illiterate basically in which Paul
Krugman suggests that life expectancy is
declining in red states and it's
increasing in blue states and this is
due to red state and blue state
governance well as well see in just a
second that does not make a whole hell
of a lot of sense so Paul Krugman says
he his column is titled America's red
state death trip now again let me just
point out if you're going to attribute
the declining life expectancy in red
states and rising life expectancy in
blue states to governance itself then
you would also have to attribute
presumably income inequality in blue
area
that is rising steadily and faster than
in red areas to Liberal governance so
which is it or is it possible that both
of these trends are being driven by
broad national trends not by local
governance that the problem of life
expectancy is not being driven by the
governance in Georgia any more than the
problem of income inequality is being
driven by policy in New York now there
are things around the fringes that can
exacerbate these problems obviously if
you are in New York for example and you
create rent control policies that
basically prevent new building this is
going to increase the price of rent over
time and what you're going to end up
with is more people living on the street
right there are policies you can take
that are going to exacerbate the problem
but the underlying trends are actually
broader and everybody is struggling to
deal with them so simplistically boxing
this into life expectancy going down in
red states because red states are badly
governed or income inequality going up
in blue states because blue states are
badly governed this is ignoring the
underlying trend and what exactly is
driving all of this so Paul Krugman
being kind of a fool does exactly this
he has a piece today as I say titled
America's red state death trap he says e
pluribus unum out of many one is one of
America's traditional mottos and you
might think it would be reflected in
reality we aren't after all just United
politically we share a common language
the unrestricted movements of goods
services and people is guaranteed by the
Constitution shouldn't this lead to
convergence in the way we live and think
in fact however the past few decades
have been marked by growing divergence
among regions along several dimensions
all closely correlated in particular the
political divide is also increasingly an
economic divide well I think that it is
also fair to say that the economic
divide is also increasingly a political
divide so the arrow of causality may run
either way while Krugman is trying to
say is because your red state your
backward
well maybe it's possible that because
red states are being left behind
economically in a lot of ways because
everybody's moving to major metro areas
that that is causing people to vote for
big vote for Republican policies in
order to allow them the opportunity to
grow economically if you vote for big
state policies what you end up doing is
actually driving down your opportunity
in those states so it's people who are
voting their own interest and there's
this peculiar idea on the left that if
you built Republican you're always
voting against your own interest if you
are not wealthy and this is something
that's put forward by Thomas Frank and a
book called what's the matter with
Kansas and it's idiot
maybe people are voting in their
economic interest they just don't
perceive their economic interests in the
same way that Thomas Frank does and
maybe they also perceive that their
economic interests are tied very closely
into their social interests and that
having a left that crams down social
policy that cuts against Church that
cuts against family is quite bad for
their local community and as we'll see
that is actually the trend what we are
actually seeing right now is two trends
in the United States one is is
economically leading to greater income
inequality which again I've never saw
I've never seen income inequality itself
as a huge problem simply because if
everybody's GDP per capita is growing
meaning if you are earning more than you
did last year not per capita right if
you are earning more than you did last
year why do you care that somebody else
is earning more than they did last year
at a greater rate than you are mean
that's just pure jealousy but if we are
concerned with income inequality then
our new knowledge-based economy is
creating a sort of bubble and income
inequality bubble and at the same time
we are a quickly secularizing country
and those two things are not going to
hit everybody equally they're not gonna
hit every area equally the income
inequality bubble is going to hit
specifically the areas where income is
the highest right which would be the big
cities and the and the Social Policy
bubble is going to hit those areas
specifically that in the past were
reliant on social institutions like
churches and marriage and now no longer
are engaging in those sorts of
activities I'll explain in just one
minute first let's talk about your sleep
quality so the fact is that if you have
kids you may not sleep that great but
when you are sleeping you want to be
extremely extremely comfortable well how
can you make this happen
first of all just like everything else
today you have the ability to have your
mattress personalized it to you I mean
it's a wondrous wondrous era Hewett
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you no matter how
you sleep on your side on your back hot
sleeper whatever helix can make your bot
what just what your body needs just head
on over to helix sleep calm /bin take
their two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life when I'm on the road I simply do
not sleep the same way I do at home and
that's because I miss my helix sleep
mattress for couples helix can even
split that mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side we've got
a ten year warranty you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but of course your go
- Hilux is offering up to 125 dollars
off all mattress orders just for our
listeners get up to 125 bucks off at
helix sleep comm slash Ben that's helix
sleep comm slash Ben for up to 125
dollars off your mattress order helix
sleep comm slash Ben go check them out
right now okay so Paul Krugman continues
and he suggests of course that red and
blue voters are moving in different
directions in terms of life expectancy
and he tries to blame that on Republican
policy Krugman says Democratic leaning
areas used to look similar to Republican
leaning areas in terms of productivity
income and education but they've been
rapidly diverging with blue areas
getting more productive richer and
better educated in the close
presidential election of 2000 counties
that supported Al Gore over George W
Bush accounted for only a little over
half the nation's economic output in the
close election of 2016
counties that supported Hillary Clinton
accounted for 64% of output almost twice
the share of Trump country now do you
think that is due to great liberal
governance or do you think that that is
due to the shift away from manufacturing
the shift toward a service and
knowledge-based economy that thrives in
major cities like San Jose the economic
trends in the United States are toward
big cities that is why people are moving
to big cities it's why the migration
patterns are all toward base cities but
says Paul Krugman the thing is the
red-blue divide isn't just about money
it's also increasingly a matter of life
and death and here's what Krugman goes
way off the rails suggesting that if you
live in a red area you're gonna die if
you live in a blue area are gonna live
people ought to shift their areas red to
blue and then they will live somehow
voting for Democrats is finding the the
well of eternal life this is back in the
Bush years I used to encourage people
encounter people who insisted the US had
the world's longest life expectancy they
hadn't looked at the data they just
assumed America was number one on
everything even then it wasn't true the
u.s. life expectancy has been below that
of other advanced countries for a long
time okay even there he is neglecting to
take out of the system homicide and car
accident death and suicide which does
actually put the United States number
one in life expectancy last time I
checked in any case he says the death
cap has however widened considerably in
recent years as a result of increased
mortality among working age Americans
this rise in mortality has in turn been
largely a result of rising and deaths of
despair drug overdoses suicides and
alcohol the rise in these deaths has led
to declining overall life expectancy for
the past few years but then he analyzes
the states and what he finds is the
divergence among states is striking he
says I looked at states that voted for
Donald Trump
the states that voted for Clinton in
2016 and calculated average life
expectancy weighted by their 2016
population in 1990
today's red and blue states had almost
the same life expectancy since then
however life expectancy in Clinton
states has risen more or less in line
with other advanced countries compared
with almost no gain in Trump country at
this point blue state residents can
expect to live more than four years
longer than their red state counterparts
okay what he's trying to do is point the
arrow the wrong way and this is a very
obvious statistical trick that he's
playing right he is suggesting that the
states that are red in 2016 if you go
back to 1990 they were pretty equal in
life expectancy but now there's been
this big divergent gap there was only
one problem if you look in the 1992
presidential election not tonight
announced a 2016 presidential election
you'll be including states that have
been hit extremely hard by the opioid
epidemic in the states that have been
hit hard by suicide and by economic
stagnation states like Ohio and
Wisconsin and Pennsylvania and Michigan
right those states have been
increasingly cutting in a trump
direction since 1992 so in other words
it was not red state governance that
preceded the problem it was the problem
that preceded red state governance it
was the problem that preceded red state
voting right it was those problems made
people vote more Republican why because
they were looking for a rebuilding of a
social fabric as will explain I Paul
Krugman's entire column is directed
toward the idea that it's not rising
secularism it's not social liberalism it
is just that red states for have an
expanded Medicaid or something but of
course that's not the case that doesn't
explain things like suicide and the
opioid epidemic because Medicaid doesn't
do anything about suicide increasing
Medicaid has no correlation with the
rates of suicide in a particular
community and in fact nobody even knows
really why suicide happens or how to
chart suicide I mean there have been
fairly significant studies done on
significant racial differences in
suicide if it were simply a case of
despair or being victimized by the
American system or or cultural values
then suicide patterns make no sense I
mean like take for example racial
suicide statistics black folks in the
United States do not commit suicide
white folks in the United States
absolutely commit suicide at an
exorbitant rate so what is that about
nobody really knows the answer to any of
that but Paul Krugman basically just
shocks all of this up to to Republican
politics and then
and then I love this he's sort of
sidelines the one factor that is pretty
obvious he says there's been a striking
divergence in behavior and lifestyle
that must be affecting mortality for
example the prevalence of obesity has
soared across all America since 1990 but
obesity rates are significantly higher
in red states okay so is the suggestion
that conservatism leads to being fat
because you're going to have to explain
that one but says Krugman really what
this is it shows that William bar the
Attorney General is not telling the
truth when he talks about the evil
imaginations of militant secularists
because people who are conservative have
suggested that the big problem in the
United States with regard to lower
lowered more toward life expectancy and
increased mortality rate but that is
largely due to secularizing values and
Krugman says well if that's true then
why exactly are these rates rising in
red states and the answer is because
these policies are actually
disproportionately affecting people in
red states because people in red states
are disproportionately not in the major
growing metropolitan areas hey that's
the actual answer to this question yes
economics is tied to social policy but
liberal social policy combined with with
a weaker economy leads to deaths of
despair it leads to social stagnation it
leads to a lack of social networking
that allows people to rise from poverty
so these two phenomenon in the end are
tied together because they are indeed
broad national trends so I'm not talking
about city policy in New York I'm
talking about overall policy in the
United States now we can talk about the
economic policy in the United States
whether it is good or bad that has led
to this increasing divergence between
sort of the what what people have termed
the IQ economy and the manufacturing
economy in other words the the
intellectual capital economy the San
Jose's and the silicon valley's of the
world and the New York finance capital
of the world kind of stuff and the
manufacturing base and we can talk about
trade policy whether we ever should have
cut a deal with China in order to open
up trading again I think the statistics
show that it was good for the United
States I think the best case for cutting
off trade with China is actually to
damage China not to help the United
States free trade generally benefits
both parties but that does not mean
they're not certain areas that are left
behind but with that said if we are
talking about the impact of social
policy social policy does not trickle
down evenly social policy does not
trickle down evenly
people who are economically successful
can afford more mistakes than people who
are economically non successful areas
the
more economically benefited our areas
that are going to be able to survive
social liberal policy better but also
those tend to be areas where people
don't actually live the way they preach
and that is the really deep point here
is that the blue areas many blue areas
in the United States the fact is that
children out of wedlock in those areas
in many cases is actually lower than in
many red state areas where people are
supposedly more religious I'll explain
in in just one second because Charles
Murray has done some heavy research on
this sort of stuff and we will get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about how you can preserve your family
memory so this is a very very important
thing to do I think it is probably the
most important just for your family the
most important gift you can make this
holiday season is something that
preserves your family memories and just
as an example last night my wife and I
visited somebody in our community whose
father had passed away and a lot of the
memories that this person had on the
were based in kind of new video but a
lot of the old video was probably
moldering out in her garage and was not
accessible to her well look the fact is
that as time moves on you want to be
able to look back and all the things you
did with your kids all the things you
did with your parents and you want all
that to be accessible you don't want all
of that in boxes falling apart in your
garage so what you should do is you
should take all of that stuff which
basically is junk but it's precious junk
and sends it into legacy box and they
will digitize it all of it for you that
is what legacy box does they the the
process from starts finishes really easy
you go online you purchase the Box you
need they send you a legacy box kit and
you fill them with all your media you
slap on the prepaid mailing label and
you send it back and then legacy box
takes it from there and a couple of
weeks you get all your originals back
plus perfectly preserved digitally
ready to watch share and relive which is
just awesome
so well everybody is going crazy trying
to get the best deals just go over to
legacy box comm because they have a an
amazing deal you get 60 percent off all
cyber monday orders which is still
carrying over to today order your legacy
box today to take advantage of legacy
boxes cyber monday sale for a limited
time take an unprecedented 60 percent
off go to legacy box comm slash men to
get 60 percent off your first order
super important present great for
parents great for siblings great for you
save your time and memories go to legacy
box comm slash pen and save 60 percent
again legacy box comm slash pen and save
60 percent okay so again Paul Krugman is
to make the argument over the New York
Times that because suicide rates and
opioid epidemic rates are rising in red
states that it is red state policy
responsible for that not social
liberalism not the liberalizing of
social attitudes but this is not in fact
true that is that is incredibly
simplistic the reason it's so simplistic
is because it ignores the fact that this
divergence has been going on for years
and is not merely a red state blue state
thing it's actually an urban rural thing
in many cases charles murray has been
writing about this for years who were a
great book called coming apart
back in 2012 we had a piece in The Wall
Street Journal specifically talking
about all of this the back in 2012
Raymond this is almost a decade ago now
he said people are starting to notice
the Great Divide the Tea Party sees the
aloofness and a political elite that
thinks it knows best and orders the rest
of America to fall in line the Occupy
movement sees in economic elite that
lives in mansions and flies on private
jets each is right about an aspect of
the problem that problem is more
pervasive than either political or
economic inequality but we face now is a
problem of cultural inequality he says
our common Civic culture has unraveled
we have developed a new upper class with
advanced education often obtained at
elite schools sharing tastes and
preferences that set them apart from
mains from America at the same time we
have developed a new lower class
characterized not by poverty but by
withdrawal from America's core cultural
institutions and Charles Marie puts
together this model that he uses in his
book coming apart two fictional
neighborhoods he labels one Belmont
after an archetypical upper middle-class
suburb near Boston and Fishtown after a
neighborhood in Philadelphia that has
been home to the white working-class
since the Revolution for purposes of
clarity Murray just did this research on
white Americans right so he can be
accused of any sort of racial bias in
his research to be assigned to Belmont
the people in the statistical nationwide
databases that he drew from must have at
least a bachelor's degree and work as a
manager physician attorney engineer
architect scientist college professor or
content producer in media in other words
members of this IQ economy to be
assigned to Fishtown they must have no
academic degree higher than a high
school diploma if they work it must be
in a blue-collar job a low skill service
jobs such as cashier or a low-skilled
white-collar job at such as male clerk
or receptionist people who qualify for
the Belmonts constituency they're about
20% of the white population in the US as
of 2012 aged thirty to forty nine people
who qualified for the Fishtown
constituency or about thirty percent of
the white population of the United
States age thirty to forty
9 so here is what happened with a
variety of factors leading up to between
1960 and 2010 right these are the broad
social trends that I've been talking
about these are the broad social trends
that matter and they help explain the
divergence in culture that's been
happening in the United States they help
explain the fact that there are a lot of
red states that have been economically
falling behind because they are not
high-tech centers for example or because
they're old manufacturing towns and why
they're falling apart is only partially
economic and cannot be solved simply by
government intervention ISM top down in
blue state areas in a blue state way so
here's what Charles Murray found on
marriage in 1960 extremely high
proportions of whites in both belmont
and Fishtown were married 94 percent in
belmont remember belmont is just a
stand-in for sort of high-income highly
educated white folks in the united
states and 84 percent in Fishtown in the
1970s those percentages declined about
equally in both places then came the
great divergence in Belmonte marriage
stabilized during the mid-1980s standing
at 83 percent in 2010 in Fishtown
however marriage continued to slide as
of $0.20 2010 a minority just 48% were
married the gap in marriage between
belmont and Fishtown grew to 35
percentage points from just a 10 okay
that is a massive massive divergence in
terms of marriage so is that due to
economics so some people like Tucker
Carlson actually would argue yes that is
due to economics he would argue that
because people lost manufacturing jobs
and because women want men who earned
more than they do that women stops
getting married to men and therefore
marriage rates decline and so we have to
somehow subsidize these manufacturing
jobs to come back and that's gonna fix
the entire problem the problem is that
that actually does not explain the
statistical that's here the facts is
that the income in among the so-called
fish towners here the income is about
the same in 2010 as it was in 1960 so it
really is not about that Ray Charles
Murray said it's not that white
working-class males can no longer make a
family wage that enables them to marry
the average male employed in a working
class occupation earned as much in 2010
as he did in 1960 and it's not that a
bad job market led to scourge men to
drop out of the labor force labor force
drop out increased justice faster in the
boom years of the 80's 90's and 2000's
as it did during bad years instead
according to charles murray the reforms
of the 1960s jump-started the
deterioration and the device
between Belmont and Fishtown so to go
back to that divide and this is again
the important divide that's happening in
the United States it explains a lot of
the political divisions in the United
States be ripping away of core common
values that have disproportionately
affected areas that were reliant on
those common values I think the fact is
that if my synagogue disappeared in in
my community the people who would be
disproportionately affected in terms of
their daily life are the people who are
reliant on the social net that exists at
my synagogue high income earners
would feel it in terms of not seeing
people on Shabbat but in terms of
receiving charity needing a handout
being able to reach out to other people
they would not feel it at all the people
who'd be hurt the most by the
disappearance of the show would be the
people who are reliant on the shul for
that social fabric there's a lot of air
SATs social fabric that exists for
high-income people highly educated
people they associated people from the
office and from their colleges but if
you're living in an area where that
social fabric does not exist and then
social liberalism undercuts all of the
other institutions the bottom falls out
this is why Paul Krugman he says well
you haven't seen opioid epidemics and
suicide rates increasing in Europe yes
because people haven't been reliant on
Church for the last 70 years in Europe
okay the decline in church going in
Europe has been going on for decades
it's not a brand new thing in Europe in
the United States it is a fairly recent
phenomenon and as the bottom falls out
you are seeing people who are falling
into a morass in just a second I'm gonna
analyze a little bit more what Charles
Marie talks about the actual cultural
divides that are under girding the the
problem of unequal life expectancy
decreases in the United States we'll get
to all that in just one second first
let's talk about communication in
marriage sometimes it can be really
rough sometimes it can be very difficult
okay well one area where it specifically
difficult is if you're talking about sex
well if you have some form of sexual
dysfunction if you have a reptile
dysfunction for example and that may be
tough to talk about but it's just a
medical problem you can get solved the
good news is with Roman you can get a
free online evaluation and ongoing care
for Edie all from the comfort and
privacy of your own home the doctor will
work with you to find the best treatment
plan if medication is appropriate Roman
will ship it to you with free two-day
shipping the whole process is
straightforward and simple and discreet
getting started is really simple you
just go to get Roman comm /ban and you
complete an online visit a reptile
dysfunction used to be tough to tackle
but now there is Roman complete an
online visit today connect with the
doctor take care of it just go to get
Roman
calm / Ben to get a free online visit in
free two-day shipping that's get Roman
calm / Ben for a free visit to get
started get Roman calm / Ben again why
why struggle with medical problem when
you can go get it taken care of
discreetly and easily and you don't
spend a fortune on it go check it out
get Roman comm / Ben GE T ro ma n comm /
Ben get Roman comm / man okay we'll get
back to more of this in just one moment
first if you're not already a subscriber
you really are missing out head on over
to daily wire.com slash subscribe for as
little as 10 bucks a month you get our
articles ad free access to all of our
live broadcasts our full show library
select bonus content our exclusive daily
water app pretty fantastic feature if
you haven't checked it out yet if you
choose the new All Access plan you get
all of these things Plus this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels that
legendary left this year's tumbler you
also get our brand-new ask me anything
style discussion feature that allows you
to engage our hosts writers special
guests on a weekly basis so stop
depriving yourself come join the fun
over at daily wire check us out at daily
wire.com / subscribe we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so talking about the gaps between sort
of red state and blue state which is
mirrored in the in the charles murray
gap between belmont and Fishtown
belmonts of course paying those high
income areas and Fishtown being sort of
low income areas less educated areas
manufacturing based areas he's already
talked about the marriage gap which
emerged in the 1980s and has completely
diverged these two populations also
there's a massive single parenthood gap
another aspect of marriage the
percentage of children born to unmarried
women showed just as great a divergence
at charles Murray this is back as of
2012 though politicians and media
eminences are too frightened to say so
non-marital births are problematic on
just about any measure of development
you can think of children who are born
to unmarried women fare worse than
children of divorce and far worse than
children raised in intact families in
1960 just 2% of all white birds from
non-marital when we first started
recording the education levels of
mothers in nineteen seventy six percent
of births to white women with no more
than a high school education women with
the Fishtown education we're out of
wedlock by 2008 44% were non-marital
among college-educated women at
bellomont less than six percent of all
births were out of wedlock as of 2008 up
from 1% in 1970 okay so that means that
there is now a 38-point
discrepancy between people who are who
are high school educated working those
manufacturing jobs in Fishtown
as opposed to white workers in belmont
but it's those people in belmonts who
are preaching the social liberalism that
has bled down to the lower levels and
pushed the social policy that has
actually incentivized that sort of
behavior and that has had
disproportionate impact this is also
true of industriousness according to
charles murray the norms for work and
women were revolutionized after 1960 but
the norm for men putatively has remained
the same healthy men are supposed to
work in practice though that norm has
eroded everywhere in Fishtown the change
has been drastic and and just to clarify
the data the data that he's been using
so far has been 1960 to 2010 he cut off
this data on on work in March 2008
before the recession so that he was not
comparing apples to oranges Charles
Morris is the primary indicator of the
erosion of industriousness in the
working class is the increase of prime
age males with no more than a high
school education who say they are not
available for work they're out of the
labor force that percentage went from a
low of 3 percent in 1968 to 12 percent
in 2008 12 percent may not sound like
much until you
about the men were talking about men
aged 30 to 49 when everybody is
basically supposed to be working of the
men in Fishtown who had jobs 10% worked
fewer than 40 hours a week in 1960 a
figure that grew to 20% by 2008 in
Belmont the number rose from 9% in 1960
to 12% in 2008 in other words a lot of
people are working a lot less in
lower-income areas also there's been a
surge in crime in a lot of areas that
are poorer also in religiosity right
this is it this is the big one I think
the decline in religiosity again contra
Paul Krugman the decline in religiosity
is actually not affected people in upper
income blue areas as much as it has
people in lower-income red areas this by
the way was mirrored by data that
suggested that Trump voters in red areas
were actually less likely to go to
church on a weekly basis then typical
Republicans who were hesitant about
Trump in 2016 in other words there was a
lot of talk about religiosity going into
the 2016 election but the fact is there
were a lot of people who sort of overtly
identified as religious but weren't
spending an awful lot of time in church
who voted for President Trump in 2016
which makes a lot of sense again these
are people who feel like the social the
social values that undergirded their
lived experience were crumbling right
there their lives were falling apart
before them because a lot of the
institutions under assault by the Left
were being destroyed and they were the
people who felt it disproportionately if
you went to church and you continued to
go to church before Trump and after
Trump well then Trump's presence in the
White House made you feel more
comfortable but it didn't fundamentally
change your life if however you were in
it you were in an area that was dying
jobs were leaving your church had fallen
apart and Trump came in promising to
restore all that it was a huge deal hey
when it comes to religiosity you see the
gap so here is what charles murray says
he says it is worrisome for the culture
that the u.s. as a whole has become
markedly more second where since 1960 it
is especially worrisome that Fishtown
has become much more secular than
belmont again this runs against the
prevailing narrative of secular elites
versus a working-class still clinging to
religion but evidence from the general
social survey and the most widely used
databases on American attitudes and
values does not leave much room for
argument for example suppose we defines
a facto secular as someone who either
professes no religion at all or who
attends a worship service no more than
once a year for the early GSS surveys
conducted from 1972 to 1970
629 percent of belmonts can that's the
upper income people and 38% to Fishtown
fell into that category over the next
three decades secularization did indeed
grow in Belmonte
from 29% in the 1970s to 40% in the GSS
surveys taken from 2006 to 2010 but it
grew even more in Fishtown these
low-income areas from 38% to almost 60%
almost 60% this has led to wide
variances in culture it's led people
eating different things it's led to
people associating in different ways and
sleds people vacationing in different
places so charles murray points out that
basically the two america's narrative is
very true and it's been it's been
increased over time by the destruction
of exactly the social institutions that
William bar is worried about being
destroyed so in Paul Krugman says well
why are things so bad in the red states
it's because in effect nationalized
policy across the United States which
has forced secularization and
incentivized personally irresponsible
behavior has had a deeper impact in the
areas that are less economically
successful than in the areas that are
economically successful which is exactly
what you would expect that is exactly
what you would expect so in the end does
it come down to policy at least in part
yes it comes down to social policy and
it also comes down to broad-based
economic policies that disincentivize
strong personal behavior Russ dude had
has a really good piece over at the New
York Times today talking about the the
leftist view of marriage the liberal
view on marriage right now and it should
be noted that Ross dude had as much more
of a government interventionist than I
am
he tends to believe the idea that if we
just shore up those manufacturing wages
that somehow marriage will increase in a
lot of these red state areas I have a
lot more doubt about that I think that
the social change that has been wrought
is not fixable simply by putting more
cash in people's pockets I think that
it's actually the other way around I
think if you make good marital decisions
you are more likely to be wealthy you're
more likely to succeed in life so again
I think that the arrow is reversed the
arrow of causality is being reversed
here but here's the part of roost
Rostow has column that's really
interesting he says to be extremely
impressionistic I would divide the
modern progressive approach to marriage
into three distinct phases in the first
phase which covers the 1960s through the
1980s there is a clear liberal led
attack on the institutional form of
marriage as it exists
then on the legal and cultural structure
that privileged heterosexual wedlock
pushed couples towards its rules and
rituals and then constrained them from
divorce this assault was undertaken in a
spirit of social optimism in the name of
personal empowerment and eventually
female equality and infused with the
confidence that the old legal and moral
structures were simply oppressive the
second phase had called the period of
reconsideration in which liberals
continued to believe that the core legal
and social changes from the 60s and 70s
had been necessary and just but
increasingly acknowledged that the
larger cultural revolution had incurred
significant costs liberals in this
period continue to support no-fault
divorce and legal abortion continued to
regard sexual fulfillment as an
essential good and premarital chastity
as an unrealistic ideal but from the Dan
Quayle was right arguments of the early
1990s onward they also conceded that
marriage is probably generally better
for kids and maybe especially boys that
monogamy is often preferable to
promiscuity and divorce is often
undesirable that welfare policy
shouldn't discourage wedlock and should
maybe even encourage it and that the
declines of marriage at least
contributed to the post-1960 struggles
of the working-class he says says doubt
happen he says I think that this
liberalism of nuance had pretty serious
limits in particularly its favored
models of marriage as a capstone on long
periods of professional development and
sexual exploration rather than as a
foundation for adulthood and a home for
adult sexuality was linked inextricably
to the educated classes privileged and
ambitious self-control and didn't work
as well outside the precincts of the
meritocracy in other words doubt had is
saying that your rejiggered version of
marriage does not work for people who
are living in Fishtown but says doubt
notwithstanding its blind spots this
liberal worldview was and is essentially
pro marriage in the sense of believing
it's good for society to have a single
normative destination to which most
couples arrive over the last 10 years
however and again I acknowledge this is
impression a success to have I think
we've reached a third phase in liberal
attitudes towards marriage a new
outworking of cultural individualism
that may eventually render the nuanced
liberalism that my colleagues described
obsolete this new face is incomplete and
contested it includes elements in me to
feminism especially whose ultimate
valence could theoretically be congenial
to cultural conservatives but in general
the emerging progressivism seems hostile
not only to anything tainted by
conservative religion or gender
essentialism
but to any idea of sexual or
reproductive
period outside of a bureaucratically
supervised definition of consent in
other words there is no norm that
dictates sort marriage or heterosexual
monogamy or having children in the
confines of marriage
dad hat says this new view of marriage
is dis inclined to regard lifelong
monogamy as anything more than one
choice among many one script to play
with or abandon one way of being whose
decline should not necessarily be
mourned and who's still outsized
cultural power probably requires further
deconstruction to be anything more than
a patriarchal holdover a prison and a
trap he says it does not feel like a
coincidence this new phase tracked with
the recent decline in childbearing if
the new liberal hostility to marriage is
normative institution is not one of the
ideological causes of our latest post
familial ratchet it is at least a post
facto ideological excuse in which the
frequent prestige media pitches for
polyamory or open marriages or escaping
gender norms entirely are there to
reassure people who might otherwise
desire a little more normativity and a
few more children in their lives and
that it's all cool because they're in
the vanguard of a revolution kay Dowd
hat is entirely correct about all of
this he's entirely correct about all
this and so if you wondered why the
cultural Wars matters so much this is
why the culture wars matters so much and
I present to you as Exhibit A in the
pitch that the left is making this
article from yesterday in the New York
Times by an associate professor of
Religious Studies at Skidmore College by
Bradley Onishi saying could I be my own
soul mate
could I be are you your own soul mate
the article describes Emily Watson the
actress and Liz oh the wrapper and
flautist who are both saying that they
are their own one that they are self
coupling this religion professor Onishi
he says for most people the idea of self
coupling may be jarring but a closer
look might reveal it to be more of an
end points of a trend marriage rates
have been declining steadily since the
1970s many of us are dating more but
somehow going on fewer dates sex is
safer and less burdened with shame than
in the past and seemingly more available
while we're having less of it than we
were a generation ago despite all these
mixed signals most of us are still
looking for the one he says according to
Stephanie Kunz author of the 2005 book
marriage a history finding the one used
to be about completion in the 19th
century the rise of the market economy
divided the sexes men into the world of
bread winning work and women into that
of unpaid domestic labor when these two
spheres were brought together in
marriage mrs. Koontz wrote they produced
a perfect well-rounded whole that's
ignoring you know the several thousand
years before that were marriage
was actually a pretty congenial
relationship this approach to
partnership we're in two members of
opposite sex complete each other was
essentially religious in origin
complementarianism for the theologians
out there a well-known example being the
biblical adage that two shall become one
and also are calls Plato's symposium one
of the earliest purveyors of the social
mayn't myth where the comic poet
Aristophanes explains that humans were
once united in pairs but then were split
into unhappy halves by zoos the idea of
completion harkens to a time when women
were economically and socially dependent
on men and marriage was reserved for
heterosexual couples today says this
columnist instead of a life defining
relationship many of us now see a
partnership as one part of a puzzle that
includes a career family a social life
personal wellness volunteer work and
creative or recreational outlets a
relationship is not the foundation of
selfhood but only a piece and this is
exactly what doubt hat is talking about
the redefinition of marriage into one
choice among many just something that
you do if you feel like it the problem
is that that may work for a very I would
say very very limited coterie of people
who read the New York Times it does not
work broadly across the United States
but our cultural institutions are all
nationalized Hollywood is nationalized
Netflix is nationalized The New York
Times is nationalized Facebook is
nationalized and that means that the
social bleed-over affect the social
trickle down effect of leftist social
policy which by the way is not even
engaged in by people at the upper
echelon in places like New York in
California one of the peculiar things
you'll find about Hollywood is the same
people who are routinely preaching the
virtues of bleeding-edge social leftism
get rid of marriage have any
relationship you want open marriages
polyamory those same people tend to get
married at higher rates than a lot of
people who are actually not living in
those areas and they tend not to have
kids out of wedlock particularly a lot
and if they do have kids out of wedlock
they can afford it because they're very
wealthy okay so those those social
messages do not apply equally to
everyone in other words just as with
every other policy in human life not all
policies affect everybody equally the
fact that that folks on the Left seem to
think that policies undertaken by
liberal elites over at the New York
Times or in Hollywood that those
policies affect people in in down
trodden economic areas the same way that
they do in Upper elite establishments
that discarded religion as a social
fabric
decades ago just demonstrates
Mendes level of ignorance so trying to
reshift these definitions of fundamental
institutions that is indeed creating a a
phenomenon in which the United States is
dividing so these two phenomena income
inequality rising the changes in the
economy and the bleed-over of social
liberalism this is leading to a toxic
brew now there are people on the right
and the left who think that the way to
fix this is to fix the economic side
right the way you're gonna do this is
with redistribution ISM you got Andrew
yang proposing universal basic income on
the Democratic side or you have people
like as I've said Tucker Carlson talking
about regulating out of existence
self-driving cars stopping economic
progress limiting trade bringing back
all these jobs to manufacturing areas as
though that's ever really going to
happen I have serious doubts about that
considering the technology has basically
put a lot of these jobs out of
commission and then there is the the
stuff that is actually in the control of
the people who are living today and that
is making the next right decision that
is making the right decision right the
fact is that there are certain factors
in your life that are fundamentally
going to guarantee that you have a
better shot at life finishing high
school not having kids out of wedlock
getting married right these things
actually change your life in ways for
the better and the fact that our culture
is so focused in on a sort of Marxist
materialism in which if we solve your
economic circumstance that this will
solve all of your other problems this is
not right this is not right
solving the problem of making right and
moral decisions that better your life
that is how your life gets better and
that means taking seriously the
fundamental social institutions they've
been broken by the left since the 1960s
focusing on restoring those because
those are things you can do not things
that you have to wait for some
government Savior to do and by the way
those government saviors they ain't
showing up again income inequality is
breaking out in major blue cities or
they've gotten rid of the social
institutions and where the ladder to
success doesn't exist even for the
underclass in those cities themselves
forget about red areas versus blue areas
in the cities themselves you need a
restoration of personal responsibility
in order to lead to a restoration of the
ladder to success that does exist from
people who make the best possible
decisions okay time for a quick thing I
like and then a quick thing that I hate
so things that I like today I know
there's a lot of heavy material here's
some light material there's a
as you know I love baseball books
there's a good baseball book by Kevin
Reedy and Ryan spanner it's a lot of fun
called incredible baseball stats great
great bathroom book the coolest
strangest stats and facts in baseball
history and it summarizes sort of most
interesting stats for every baseball
team so if you're a baseball fan
check it out incredible baseball stats
by kevin reavie and Ryan spanner if
you're not a baseball fan Oh
deal with it I'll have a different thing
I like tomorrow okay time for a quick
thing that I hate okay so I'm very
friendly with the Tucker Carlson thing
Tucker is a really good guy I've had
Tucker on the Sunday special someone in
Tucker keeps saying and it's driving me
a little bit of a wall and I just have
to point this out
so Tucker keeps saying on his show that
we should side with Russia against
Ukraine I don't understand why he is
saying this Russia is in fact a
tyrannical state run by a KGB operative
who would like to see the restoration of
the Soviet Union Ukraine for all of its
corruption and all of its problems is
not that right it's a country that is
attempting to westernize and as a
country that is attempting to be
integrated into the European Union the
idea that we should side with Russia as
it makes territorial incursions into
surrounding areas is a bizarre one this
is the second time in like two weeks
that Tucker has sort of suggested this
thing the first time he walked it back a
little bit and said he was joking this
time he did not here is here is Tucker
suggesting and that Vladimir Putin for
all his faults doesn't hate the u.s. the
way that some of the media do that is
highly questionable considering again
that Vladimir Putin has suggested that
he'd like to go back to the days of the
Cold War in which the USSR was directly
pitted against the power of the United
States the rest of the dummies Vladimir
Putin isn't a real person with actual
ideas and priorities in a country and
beliefs no he stopped being that long
ago he's a metaphor a living metaphor
he's the boogeyman
step out of line and you're a traitor in
league with Vladimir Putin let's put his
picture on the screen can we get his
picture on the screen yeah
please the irony of course is that Putin
for all his faults does not hate America
as much as many of these people do okay
mm-hmm I mean they're that last line I'm
gonna go no on that again then that was
a member of the KGB and then Tucker on
the same show urged the United States to
take sides with Russia over Ukraine
while talking with representative Jim
Jordan here was that I loved your
monologue I think you nailed it exactly
right
I mean I should say for the record I'm
totally opposed to these sanctions and
and I don't think that we should be at
war with Russia and I think we should
probably take the side of Russia if we
have to choose between Russian Ukraine
that is my view but but even with that
tell me no but like okay well my head it
is haha it can't be both I mean so look
you got exist right ok so again the
context for this discussion is the
discussion about Ukrainian interference
in the 2016 election and all the rest of
it
but you don't have to side with Russia
in order to point out that Ukrainian
interference from the Ukrainian embassy
to Alexander chalupa with regard to the
DNC that that was a bad thing two things
can be true at once
Ukraine trying to militate in favor of
Hillary Clinton was a bad thing was a
bad thing also Russia is an
extraordinarily nefarious force in
today's world they are incredibly
aggressive they have an economy that is
collapsing in on itself right now which
means that Vladimir Putin has to get
more aggressive a serious demographic
crisis because they just didn't have
babies for years and now they have this
they have this heavy state burden that
is not being borne by anybody which
means typically that they're gonna have
to get aggressive on the
extraterritorial front they're going to
have to endanger NATO allies this
decided with Russia over Ukraine and
that's that's some pretty wild stuff
right there from from Tucker and again I
appreciate what Tucker does I think the
Tucker is is a great fighter against the
hardcore left but that is I have nothing
I have nothing to say there except that
that is a horrible idea
all right we'll be back here later today
for two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the bench Bureau
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pablo why douse key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina hair and makeup is by
Jess well alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clavin
[Music]